quick rather quick draw in the first one
do you think we'll we'll see some more
action in this one David
the ready Duda is playing a very
provocative opening this one I've played
myself many times before is white it's
the refi opening but this last Pawn push
does invite black Central born Black's
deep one to push forward in the center
and this is a significant risk it
doesn't have a great reputation for
white and okay manager doesn't play the
critical move he doesn't seize the ball
by the horns he captures a pawn and he's
trying to make this look like a Queen's
Gambit accepted it looks like black
grabbed a pawn the Queen's Gambit and
the white later won the pawn back but
white Central Pawn the Deep one hasn't
committed to the center so wet is very
flexible in these types of positions
yeah and intriguingly and checking the
database and I can see that the
mamajarov has played this before and
lost although it was a Blitz game okay
so he lost with the black pieces with
the black pieces yeah against a deck
okay strong Romanian Grandmaster yeah
and
he seems to be nearly repeating the same
type of approach so it's just simply
just to push this Pawn forward and
develop the pieces and the big
difference between this game and the
first game we saw today is that all the
pieces remain on the board and they
likely will for at least the next 10 or
15 moves
maybe that's optimistic 15 moves but for
the next 10 moves it's just about
keeping pieces on the board maybe dude
at some point will extend in the center
with white white has two pawns on the E
and D files in the middle black only has
one so
um unless Duda is really in the mood to
make exchanges and kind of uh finds a
way then I think we'll get a much bigger
fight
and uh what do you think if I could
kind of surprising Choice from dude in a
way I haven't seen him play like this
many times before
um I wasn't necessarily surprised by
judah's opening choice I was surprised
more by uh Mama jar of capturing that
born because it's not something I've
seen too often at the higher levels and
I think what we're going to see here is
uh again what I call Baseline tennis yes
you know white simply going to Castle
Black's going to also develop light
Square Bishops all the pieces are going
to be within their own turf and they'll
be just uh just lobbying those shots to
one another and then when there is a
break in the center the position will
explode yeah so not gonna explode yet
Duda thinking the most natural move here
I guess would be to Castle the white
king
um you could push a couple of different
pawns as well but no now for the first
time today this night jumper surprised
us it surprised Us in the first game and
uh surprising again I guess there's a
specific idea in mind but it looks a bit
superficial quite using the same piece
twice in the opening we criticized
mamajara for that earlier and Juventus
this is a novelty not a novelty it's
been played before okay but just one
person tried it out and it was a draw so
I'm guessing the idea as you referred to
was basically to stop black um
developing the light squared Bishop yeah
so this is always the problem piece in
actually many black openings but uh the
whole idea for black would normally be
to attack this bishop and this would
allow white to jump forward with the
queen and hit the rook in the corner I'm
not sure how effective this is the rook
in the corner isn't quite trapped The
Rook can actually move one square so
this would have been maybe okay White's
Bishop Under Fire might have to retreat
but instead Mama draw have moved at
night and Duda he's really been creative
this Knight in the center was challenged
and he's defended it with the F Pawn you
nearly never see this
in the reti-opening white pushing
forward with the F Pawn the ideas just
to defend the Knight yeah it feels like
he's borrowing ideas from other openings
like maybe in Sicilian Defense where you
get this particular eye idea of just
maybe retreating the Knight and then
lunging forward with the F Pawn again
sorry I cannot resist it I just love
pushing my pawns forward I love just
elongating those diagonals uh can't help
it yeah dude it loves it too Ivanka yeah
he's pushing those pawns forward and I I
do think it's asking a little bit much
from the position I I mean if I were
black I would just look at my opponent
and go well maybe what's stopping me
from but perhaps uh kicking back the
bishop yeah for example attacking this
bishop maybe do this idea again is the
same to attack this rook in the corner
maybe this is a bit awkward to deal with
now the big difference is that if
Black's Rook moves the White Knight
could jump forward a lot of calculation
to be done here it's not 100 clear the
consequences of this one for example it
could get really complicated if black
pins the White Knight along this
diagonal but uh yeah some calculation to
be done already do you think Duda if
he's given time he'll start throwing
more pawns forward you mentioned you
love pushing full yeah possible the
whole hog this is what we want policy we
had from Ginger GM early on in the show
[Laughter]
in your uh
as accurate as an artist so either way
it looks like duda's intention is to
attack and uh Shaq is facing the attack
this time uh he's not used to that
situation he normally wants to be the
one on the front foot interesting
strategy from Duda I do like where his
Bishops are placed as well normally when
you have Bishops like this on the long
diagonals and that's the signal go
forward
forward he's pushing the F Pawn and
do that on the front foot
okay so this
look like a game that will end up with a
winner or at least on chaos
chaos I think most likely yeah too early
maybe to say win lose draw but dude is
going for it do you think this is a
strategy in general you Banker against
solid with black attack with white whoa
I did have a look at the database
earlier on this morning and I did check
out their games that these two have
played especially on the tour and it
just seems that they play very wild
games you know one of them I mean it's
always both of them are at fault here
both of them just kind of lunge for the
other they initiate this complicated
random position and then you know
something will will happen there will be
a roller coaster of a game and you'll
see a result within move 40. so uh it's
exciting anyhow and there we see a mama
jar step forward with his g-pawn perhaps
just to solidify his Pawn structure
there on the right and get ready to
develop the dark Square bishop and the
bar did not like that at all it suddenly
well now it's not suggesting itself it
was a bit over excited there it does
look very risky very counter-intuitive
to open up the diagonal of white dark
Square Bishop if you look at white start
to go Bishop on B2 the diagonal suddenly
Black's rook in the corner feels a bit
vulnerable
maybe it's fine it's holding together
for now
but I'm impressed my major I've had this
move on his radar even I would never
have dreamed of picking up that pawn
and uh okay Duda smiling too oh it looks
like he was about to smile he kind of
cut himself off now frowning again he
really looks like the boss just yeah I
know
I like David's evil laughter and we're
talking about laughter and today we're
asking you guys at home to send us your
best chess joke and work jokes says to
us uh so I was having dinner with Gary
Kasparov problem was we had a checkered
taper tablecloth and it took him two
hours to pass the salt
and Heidi the H Pawn says sorry Kyle
what does kaya scream every time she
passes by the good night in Oslo look at
them
I'm gonna start doing that now
yeah and very good maximalist asks us
which night always loses our chest
this is a nice one don't look at the
punchline oh no
I haven't seen it
um
it's very good
always looses that chest yeah
I don't know so render
surrender render
my sense of humor I love these puns I
know some people don't like them but I
do so keep them coming send us your best
chest jokes on the hashtag chess Champs
and one lucky winner will win a mug shot
of Simon on a mug yeah
very cool you guys and do that now
thinking for two and a half minutes on
this move he is in move nine and they
have played each other 14 times all
together on the tour these two leading
up to today before before today started
can you guess the score between them
seven seven no
I should have done my research seventh
area oh I meant including drawers but
yeah yeah I don't know their overall
score but I do know that until final it
went to tie breaks they both had a win a
piece and then Judah was just
overwhelmingly good and the tie breaks
and the same thing happened in the Oslo
Esports cup
so Blitz Games that's simple it's not
sure if Blitz came those are counted
here
you have to Enlighten us so uh eight
draws okay three wins each okay so it's
uh dead equal before the final starts
wow level scores yeah seven seven right
14 games yeah so they are yeah I'll
pretend I knew that yeah very good but
uh yeah that should show us both these
players very balanced
um and similar we mentioned in some
aspects of their game okay finally both
sides of castles we are out of the
opening and it's just very very tense
both sides have problem pieces black
light Square Bishop completely locked in
um I think Shaq wants to prioritize
getting that piece out and uh for white
it's the Knight on the queen side still
asleep needs to bring that to a Central
Square at some point soon
but uh yeah just a very odd Pawn
structure you nearly never see this one
white d-pawn as well sitting in front of
the White Queen that pawn normally moves
on move one or move two maybe even move
three but it's move 11 now and uh still
not advanced
so it does look a bit odd but yeah white
has control over the center for now it's
just about whether manager can bring his
pieces out could it move to the D4
square or would that be a bad move for
him I I think you're right Kyle that
might be part of the plan at some point
in the near future if we just jump in
just to highlight the plans for dude if
he wants to play a bit slower then he'll
go for development maybe move the queen
this looks like a decent Square for her
she's kind of pinning along this
diagonal some targets there white knight
could also come out it depends for
example if the white knight comes out do
you want to capture in the center with a
pawn for white this Pawn is potentially
strong potentially weak it's not clear
so that's one question if you want to be
more direct then you'll move Kaya you
can play with the pawn forward in the
center the only downside
um it's good that you open it up because
I think you have great central control
but the only downside is that now the
pawn structure is almost symmetrical so
symmetrical means both sides have pawns
on the a b e f g h files yeah so no past
Pawn potential
so if all the pieces disappear then the
pawns kind of balance each other out so
in the current position that's not the
case there is an imbalance this Pawn uh
is Advanced but it could be weak this
Pawn is nice and safe very flexible so I
think we might see this at some point
pushing forward but maybe not yet okay
I'm more expecting Judah to play with
pieces
when I prepare for opponents I always
think there's
two different types of player players
who attack with pawns players who attack
with pieces and both of these like to
play with pieces Pawn structure is maybe
secondary to them for me prawn structure
is like the number one issue in chess
I'm always looking oh I have a nice
chain here or my opponent's Pawn here
could potentially be weak maybe I can
push forward and kind of cut off the
protection of this Pawn but these two
they look for peace activity maybe more
than anyone else in worldchester right
now these two uh so I'm expecting Duda
to move the White Queen or maybe this
White Knight
so one of these two we're not doing
anything at the moment but then you with
your style would you move that pawn or
would you also not move it because you
want that passport yeah I think I would
move upon I might move this Pawn in the
corner so the reason I would move this
is because now my opponent's B Pawn is
kind of locked down if they push it
Forward at some point I could capture on
passant as if it moved one square and
for example even if there's a capture
here my opponent now I would be thinking
oh I've got a better Pawn structure
white has one isolated Pawn over here
but black has two isolated pawns so
White's Pawn structure is better long
term
but uh this is because I have very kind
of Niche thinking I'm like oh looking
for these tiny small advantages but
these two players I don't think they'll
be worrying about that they'll be
thinking about uh how to activate and
also this type of Pawn push it does tie
down the white Rook to defend this Pawn
uh okay quite long term interesting
though David does that happen a lot that
you don't actually
uh sort of suggest and show us the move
that you would play uh sometimes ah yeah
I mean it depends who we're watching if
we're watching Magnus then often the
move I suggest might be on his radar too
just because I feel that he likes the
long term grindy type of positions but
these two I'm trying to get in their
minds and I'm thinking okay Duda wants
to attack that's clearly his strategy
with this opening how would he do that
it would be bringing a queen forward or
bringing a knight forward
um it wouldn't be just a small kind of
knowing my Lucky's going to play it now
but probably not his style no I I have
to say
I was channeling that as well and uh my
first idea because uh one of the reasons
why I was also drawn to this particular
porn move is it also secures the
position of the light squared Bishop
and I I in my mind I was trying to set
up a very weird configuration okay
ah okay it basically involved the queen
trying to find make its way to the A1
Square okay so for example let's say
black plays a few moves yeah you move
your knight out I'll play another move
you move your Rook somewhere yeah maybe
you want to bring the White Queen across
I wanted this type of configuration I
mean I wasn't quite sure where to put
the Knight that was the only thing that
wasn't so again for example you want
your knight out the way yeah but you
want your queen and Bishop lined up on
this diagonal yes yeah interesting
that's uh how I was also trying to
approach the position but uh
I feel that the night is too much of a
problem piece there and meanwhile we
have seen the night move to the center
and white take a step back now
okay it's tension now between these two
Bishops white tonight it looks a bit
convoluted just dropping back to a
square that gets in the way of your
pawns but for example if the Bishops
disappear then again later you're free
to push this Pawn but I think actually
duda's long-term strategy is positional
he wants to Target this weakness this is
why we push the port forward as well
because the only Pawn that can ever
protect uh this Black Sea Pawn is its
body here on B6 but then it will always
get traded off by White's Pawn now so
actually this Pawn is not quite isolated
but it's essentially isolated and where
White's night stands at the moment
is always going to Target this guy so
it's not just locking down the position
but it's also got clear Targets in mind
this black porn's kind of cut off from
the rest of its buddies right now
interesting I mean Duda he's going
against his usual style which is
fascinating for me at least is it
tailored specifically to this one versus
one headset match
Duda has actually had a very good score
this tournament against the young Indian
players and
as Magnus said anti-young player chess
it's kind of like slow strategic and the
same could be used for malacharov he
might be the oldest player in the
tournament but he plays like a youngster
energetic so it feels like Duda is
trying to slow down the pace of the game
interesting
I like this decision actually
and both sides having their pros and
cons you know and the more I look at it
the more it's not that easy for black to
actually take those decisions you know
should he trade off Bishops should he
allow white to trade off Bishops and he
does trade off the dark Square bishop
and then the second question is like
what is black gonna do with the Knight
sitting on D7 is it going to develop is
the queen going to come out and try to
cover those dark squares oh there's so
many decisions to take here that could
potentially influence whether it's a big
Advantage for white small advantage or
just equal so critical moment right now
and whilst the mama jar is pondering as
to what to do we have another joke from
this time from Sagar Jain who says why
are our artists so bad at chess
I don't know because they like to draw
very good
but you're not bad at chess if you're
able to draw a game I would love it if I
was able to do that
winning is the joy though that's the
point of Chess but okay meanwhile there
has been a trade of Pawn so we did see
that on passant idea so White's apron
that was Far Advanced it has been traded
off but now Pawn structure we talk about
porn Islands white has one big island uh
from the Disney yeah I was actually
about to say that and I was like can I
get away with that one uh the white deep
on to the H file that's all one at porn
Island they can all protect each other
potentially but white has one isolated B
Pawn black has three porn Islands
because he has two isolated pawns the A
and C pawns uh the rest protect each
other so you want as few as possible uh
it's not like grease where you want as
many islands as possible go on a holiday
it's fine you want as few as possible in
chess
that means you have fewer weaknesses
and okay Black's night does have an
outpost I do like what Shaq's done in
terms of his Bishop Black's Bishop was
uh his worst place piece and now his
Bishops maybe his better uh best minor
piece
black Bishop on a nice long diagonal
I really like what Shaq has done you
know because he solved all his opening
problems and uh he's got a very good
piece as you mentioned a night on an
outpost that's what every Knight wants
to be and then the the queen is coming
out to cover the dark squares around the
king the Rooks will line up into the
Santa nice straightforward plan
um now is the time for Doula to find
something active to do and it must be to
do with uh relocating the Knight on the
edge of the board and put it towards the
center yeah wait it really doesn't have
that many good squares to go to with
this night so I expect the same you want
the square of anger yeah yeah so we talk
about outposts black snipe can never
ever get kicked Away by a pawn and it's
supported by its own Pawn so this is an
outpost and white tonight has the same
for example if you jump forward let's
say there's a trade of knights
um this night also can't get kicked Away
by any pawns and it's just as good as
Black's Knight next to it so these two
pieces kind of cancel each other out
but I love white tonight on the Square
to be honest nights are best also in
front of isolated pawns and that's the
case for this piece also the case for
black spawn but uh this piece is maybe
nearer the king's side so later if it
does switch to an attack White's Knight
is slightly closer in the race than
Black's night
um yeah small margins here the computer
thinks it's dead level and
I think I would choose white slightly
but uh I'm not surprised both players
decent pieces right now oh I'm surprised
actually by by the computer and you're
choosing white because I was going to
choose black really yeah oh I was I was
thinking I love Shaq's position you know
he's got a great Bishop porn Island's
Ivanka yeah
yeah this is interesting it's I mean
there's no right or wrong we're both
right in a way because it's level
chances and it's just a matter of taste
and that's why from a human aspect it's
you need to know your style in order to
know whether you want to play with
uh kind of good pieces or good Pawn
structure normally you can't choose both
here
yeah here it's uh kind of a bit of both
for each side they have great pieces but
the pawns aren't ideal
and uh yeah let's go back to the players
you mentioned Ivanka that strategy
around move 20 will start to heat up it
is heating up now oh uh by move 40 you
think normally it's going to be clear
who's going to have the advantage or
who's going to be dominating yes so next
10 15 moves next next moves are critical
and uh also I've noticed that the
positions are so sharp that the
evaluation
will often swing so often you'll see
like hey white is winning and then it
will make they will make one inaccuracy
and then oh black is winning and you go
through this turbulent ride and you're
just holding onto the edge of the seats
and you're trying to figure out
desperately what's going to happen next
and uh I mean levonne aronian said it
quite simply when you play chakra
mamajarov you have to bring your
Tactical a game too I mean you have to
be looking at every single checks
capture threats you have to be looking
at the activity of his pieces and you
have to try to contain it you know kill
the game but this is not really in dude
our style to kind of play so
methodically and logically I mean he's
also an artist yeah but he is it quite
visible that he is changing his style of
it look at this last Rook move it's just
stepping up one square he's protecting
his pawns on the second rank white has a
lot of them and it's a very slow
defensive move again it's the type of
move I love just because it covers your
ground
um you're just getting ready in case
there is some action but it's not what
we associate with Duda and uh Shaq
covering the dark squares Black start
squares around his King were previously
vulnerable so he's put a pawn to cover
for example that white knight now cannot
go towards the black king due to this
Pawn push
interesting stuff it's it's very tense
very cagey just again strategy on every
move evaluation bar heading in White's
Direction now but it is hard to see why
uh Black's pieces they are all perfectly
ready for any direct confrontation
and yeah it just again it looks like the
type of position you toss a coin you're
like oh I'll take white that's fine
white has decent chances oh toss a coin
Black's doing well too
and uh clock times though it's
definitely in Black's favor not mature
of playing much quicker than Duda
that could be relevant later not quite
Now where's Simon when we need him look
at that Harry has advanced I mean you
were talking about playing like
logically stepping forward for over
protecting everything and dude is like
okay I'm impatient now this is too deep
for me let's just go back to what I do
best and that is uh move my pawns
forward start probing Mama jara's King
side for weaknesses I like this
obviously I mean is that any surprise I
mean the next move is to lift up the
pawn one square forward but and now we
see my major of not reacting to that
move at all and instead improving his
bishop and wow the bar hates that move I
mean why it looks like a good move to me
Black's Bishop nicely centralized
controlling some key squares Black's
night as well
it looks great how come white be that
much better I still prefer white
slightly but I plus one advantage
equivalent to a pawn that's surprising
huh what could the idea be here
whoa dude is going all out attack no
more subtlety anymore all the pawns
forward he's burning The Bridges bridges
uh with great space comes great
responsibility and now it's going to be
all about those light squares in front
of the white king and whether white will
be able to generate that attack
hmm really interesting stuff this would
never have crossed my mind I've got to
say not in a million years
um this is I mentioned they prefer to
play with pieces but at the moment the
pieces are quite stuck uh so this is
duda's attempt to break his pieces open
uh give them some life and I think the
idea is actually quite a positional one
Ivanka to play the G form forward and
secure the E5 Square for the night so
for example if black weights like a
semi-useful move then yeah this Pawn
push
hits this Pawn uh hits the F Pawn now a
decision needs to be made for black this
spawn is attacked twice if you capture
then I don't think this is great whites
Rook can swing across and use the H file
later but if you block it up that's not
great either like you said the E5 Square
we talked about outposts and this is a
perfect Outpost for the White Knight
it's going to sit in the center of the
board beautifully controlling everything
it's tentacles controlling both sides of
the board and uh yeah this is really
interesting because on the face of it
superficially at least in this position
it looks like White's just opened up his
King for no reason
he's not attacking the black king you
don't have enough pieces going towards
that black king but it's just a purely
strategic
idea and that's rare when you push uh
three pawns the three-point attack
wow yeah it's uh do we think we'll see
manager of trying to prevent this by uh
going for the poor the four Pawn wall I
don't know just all of four pawns trying
to stop the white pawns matching forward
but it looks a bit shaky though that
looks very fragile I mean I mean people
will be asking us why we think it looks
shaky because after all the pawns are
old enough I was gonna ask because I
think they look powerful Mean Girls in
the high school hallway yeah it's like a
shield wall of uh Warriors this Pawn is
fine for now but I think it's actually
this Pawn that's the big weakness
because White's Queen is eyeing It Up
From Afar Black's Queen is tied down
defending it
um yeah I guess it doesn't look that
shaky if the black king kind of just
comes forward defends the other loose
Pawns
yeah it's uh it's on my radar at least I
would be very tempted to stop uh the
advance of White's Pawn by pushing the
black pawn but my major if you remember
he wants to play for pieces he always
wants to have the safer King so
temporarily White's King is a bit more
open than black king uh there's more
kind of empty squares around it so
manager if you might be looking for ways
to attack
uh for example the Black Knight could
swing across attacking the White Queen
but it's just a one Mover The White
Queen can slide to safety so that
doesn't really achieve much the Black
Knight could also jump into this Square
attack the white Rook but it's just a
one mover yeah the white Rook can move
away you haven't gained anything
so there's lots of ways of creating one
move attacks but Shaq is trying to
create a longer term plan in the current
position yes that's a doodle being
really creative I've got to admire it
yeah Breaking All the Rules in different
situations now in the opening moving the
same piece many times pushing Pawns in
front of your king it's it's not what we
teach to kind of beginners maybe but it
shows Once once you've got good pieces
your position has resources like this
one and this is a very unusual position
I mean let's face it when do we see
something like this so neither player
will be able to draw on their Bank of
patterns that they use to help them and
find their plans and I agree you know I
think it's going to we're going to see a
lot of fireworks on the board and I
disrespect that uh we will see this wall
of Pawns from mamajarov
Ah that's cool that would be very very
cool
there's time advantages nearly
disappeared Mama jar of he was four or
five minutes up on the clock
and uh spending four minutes on this one
move slides his Queen across now the
queen sits on the same diagonal as each
other so I guess it's ideas if that
diagonal opens up he's happy with the
queen exchange okay
interesting decision yeah but also is
the idea to improve the queen
put her on H6 and tax and Pawns possible
or maybe going towards the white king at
some point yeah she's allowed if she's
allowed of course
to do that very difficult decision here
well we'll see a winner in this game now
do you think it's it's imbalanced enough
porn structure is completely weird and
that normally means
very good winning chances for both sides
and he does advance with his Pawn is
that to stop the queen move yeah to stop
the queen coming out and also he's
basically saying doodle with this move
he's happy for an end game uh earlier we
talked about I mean I was kind of kind
of half joking about the porn Islands
but that will become very relevant in an
end game so no matter what black does
now with his F Pawn the Queen's they're
like he marches forward the Queens are
likely to get exchanged and uh once that
happens we will be heading towards an
end game Pawn structure is the key there
and why does he March forward with the
pawn and um not take the ball yeah I
think he just feels he wants to block
things up also this Pawn defends the
black Bishop in the middle of the board
um normally you don't want to take away
from the center if your opponent can
capture towards the center if that makes
sense uh so black decided to block and
white tonight is on that Outpost yeah
things are heating up and uh well Duda
is simply getting ready to push the H
Pawn one square forward and initiate an
attack on the right side of the board so
this means that Mama jarov has to
distract white from this plan and has to
then therefore take measures in the
center start threatening the weak Pawn
on D2 pile up the works in the middle
yeah this is why it's only weakness
right yeah yeah I mean it's the base of
the pawn chain this is a great Connect
Four Pawn chain but uh it's always the
base that's the weakest so
the problem is how to attack this one
it's not easy at all I mean can you step
forward with
a black Rook yep say The Rook moves yeah
for example even if I just slide back
with a white Bishop I'm always defending
this Pawn now twice with the Rook I'm
not sure I even want to do that to be
honest I'm very tempted as you mentioned
to start advancing what's better than
Connect Four it's connect five and this
white Pawn chain uh is going to really
clamp down on black structure actually
any end game now is just winning for
white because uh Black's King is going
to be so stuck in the corner
um yeah I mean this is one idea I really
I'm itching to get rid of this Knight
they are tempted to drop back with the
Black Knight to try and exchange it off
but the problem is I lose this Pawn
right yeah I lose a pawn at the moment
so maybe that's not possible
but how else can you get any activity as
black again you can create one move
threats you can drop the Knight back to
attack the queen but the queen moves and
what are you doing this night looks nice
but it gets in the way of blackstrokes
and why I looked at them I think White's
incomplete control
yeah I agree
um I agree actually with your radical
solution of just uh trading nights yeah
maybe this is the best in the current
position uh to just even at the cost of
a pawn to try and get rid of this piece
and managerov agrees as well process of
elimination nothing looked good for
black so get rid of your opponent's best
piece even if you're sacrificing and uh
if for example what gobbles off a pawn
right now with the white Rook then at
least okay in a position like this white
tonight is gone you can breathe the sigh
of relief
temporarily
and uh
they're still very solid as black yeah
exactly and at least you have some
freedom in the position you know the
Rooks now haven't have an open lines to
attack down you know the beeline the
A-line the queen can swing across as
well exactly and uh you do have to
remember that White's King is still very
shaky so I definitely like this move I
mean is there any way that Duda can kind
of keep control instead of grabbing the
material
um it's a good question your Banker if
we go back to the current game position
um it's this one how to keep control the
problem is if we move our Knight or if
we capture Black's night then the queen
exchange is going to happen and I'm not
sure this favors white so much
um yeah suddenly Black's Bishop is just
as good as the white Bishop
Sunny Black's Rook is on an open file
again there's a question of whether
white can be greedy and grab a pawn but
it's just upon the rest of Black's
position looks good suddenly
as
you've got an idea yeah I do have one
idea which is to capture
so not capture um just to move the
bishop to the C4 square and attack the
pawn yeah it's a big weakness not
defended makes a lot of sense I guess
black would defend or maybe block with
his own bishop and
um yeah I mean it still looks good for
white to be honest white can grab this
free porn whenever he wants but still
not easy to make any killer breakthrough
it feels like Chuck is just trying to
defend right now and do the burning time
is going to be said he's looking for
that killer blow
I think I would just grab a pawn and
just move first think later
greed can't be that bad in this position
yeah I did actually now just check for
computer evaluation and it says
basically you can do all the three
things that we mentioned okay
and it's all good for white and uh
capturing the pawn is good yeah
I think when in doubt when you've kind
of looked for the very direct attempts
sometimes you just have to go back to
simple chess I'm a big fan of simple
chess just okay take a pawn you can get
this night now take this Knight off the
board you've made small gains in that
process
here and we see due to pause I mean is
he considering capturing that night with
the queen
[Music]
possibly possibly take the game to an
end game and lower the risk bizarre yeah
the White Queen is defending you earlier
you mentioned that deep Pawn White's D2
D2 Pawn is vulnerable
so I'm expecting the pawn to take back
but maybe dude is getting nervous
doesn't stick with the queen yeah I
think this could there be a tactic on
the board no
so after
okay the Queens have come off the board
and now we're considering whether Rook
can just capture the pawn that's
available on D2 yeah Black's Rook can
get active now
I would be very tempted uh to go for
that dude nodding his head yep um my
Majora agrees he captures the porn
blacks Rook on the second rank that's
normally good White's Rook on the sixth
rank can go across and capture report as
well
so what can go a pawn up again but uh
still black is getting active for its
Pawn structure not ideal anymore those
doubled White eporns
vulnerable
it feels like Mao jar is doing a good
job of demanding but a computer says
evaluation Bar says still good for white
still good for Duda yeah
yeah one minute though can he find a
good continuation now
Charles seem calm and then control but
he has started popping his head a little
bit because the clock is taken down one
minute the position is very tense I mean
this could quickly go wrong for Shaq he
has to play very active moves and Duda
now is in full calculation mode I think
he's calculating whether to capture the
pawn whether he should spring forward
with a bishop threaten the pawn there's
so many things to get excited about and
he does move the bishop and now attacks
the pawn and at the same time offers a
trade of Rooks yeah so uh big threat on
the board another Drive needs to react I
think he might have to trade off a set
of Rooks at some point my major off I
think he has to give a check first and
The Rook comes down and now is the time
I think to offer well just to capture
that Rook yeah trade him off says no
though he steps his Rook back and this
is a really sneaky idea he's got an idea
in mind that he's actually giving up a
rook but he's going for the draw he's
going for what we call Perpetual check
so in this position he's just allowed
white to capture this Pawn this is a
double attack a check winning the
BlackRock next move but if you take the
black Rook suddenly Black Sweat gives a
check the King has to go into the corner
the black Rook moves out the way for
example here with a discover check the
white King has to move and we'll see
that kind of windmill operation as they
call it just continue forever the
position would repeat itself so the
white king can't escape
Duda has indeed captured this Pawn so
he's got the double attack the king
moves okay it went into the corner but
now if Duda wants to win he can't allow
this check or he can allow it but he has
to give his King some breathing space
he's put his King in a mating net
it's vulnerable there and now I'm
thinking okay move the white Rook on F1
move it out of the way perhaps align it
with its other rook and then
threatened to do something yeah you're
still attacking this piece he does play
that Ivanka you're right I'm very
surprised he went into the corner Shack
like you said it's just really bad in
the corner of the king no way out of
there and uh he has to deal with the
threat against The Rook I'm assuming the
Rook will move
and uh yeah let's just show your idea
for example if the Rook steps up one
square white can actually deliver
Checkmate really nicely check the bishop
can go and take this Rook but after
White Strip replaces its fellow trapped
in the corner now the king it can move
and final blow Checkmate really nice
pretty mating pattern
so actually manager doesn't have too
much choice
yeah he's gonna move this Rook he's
gonna move it somewhere safe along the
eighth rank
you could maybe flick in a check first
but I don't think that changes anything
now the key difference is that white
king doesn't go into the corner it runs
towards the center where it's much safer
no more no more kind of sensible checks
at least
so uh yeah it's Duda in control at the
moment
Shack why did he go into the corner with
the black king the black king is just so
bad here gonna be tricks against that
piece yeah I think he just wanted to
defend his Pawn I mean he was afraid
such decisions happen when uh you're not
cold and logical and you just play using
your emotions and definitely Duda now
has the upper hand yeah he has the upper
hand I'm expecting him uh sorry manager
just to move his Rook to this square or
maybe the square and the fight goes on
but white is a pawn up and with active
pieces how important is it now for Mom
there to at least keep his advantage on
the clock to make a move fast now
quite important I feel already a few
turns ago it felt like he was hustling
he was playing some quick moves they
weren't necessarily the best moves or
most accurate but he was setting traps
playing instantly
and that nearly worked for him but dude
has found a really clever way to
continue the game
to avoid that draw that drawing
mechanism that we showed
and yeah that time Advantage you're
right Kai is disappearing yeah I think
if it comes down to a pure scramble uh
Ivanka hit the nail on the head earlier
they've played two Blitz matches in
recent times these two dudas won them
both so in terms of pure speed dude is
younger he's quicker
and uh not major I think if he does
drift below 30 seconds in this game he's
gonna
find it difficult
under a minute on the clock he needs to
move the bar is loving it for young
Christoph Duda this is game two the
first one was a draw and if Duda wins
this he will take the lead
and with one more point he will win the
first match
the king does run towards the center for
Duda and the computer does not like what
Shaq's doing but Shaq is going for the
white king so he's actually lined up the
black Rook with that white king there is
a pawn in the way Black's f porn will
try to push forward blow open the line
towards its enemy King
but white hasn't moved before that
happens yeah and he Retreats his Bishop
so he's basically saying to Shaq if you
push forward with the pawn I am just
gonna go and put my Rook on F6 square
and just start looking at your rook and
the position is critical and take a look
at the bar I mean it absolutely confirms
it Duda now has a winning Advantage yeah
you're right uh sorry
um yeah the black porn this was tracks I
did to push forward to blow open this
line but it's just one move too slow if
it was Black's move he would actually be
breaking through and checkmating white
one move too slow however and your idea
coming across challenging the black rook
and actually you cannot even take this
Rook because now a white Pawn replaces
it I'm not even sure which Pawn but one
of these two will March forward and make
a new Queen now
and uh we don't see that from mamajarov
instead we see the Rook move we saw
Black's Rook try to slide down with a
check oh look at this it's a past pawn
two squares away
this King in the corner is just as weak
as White's King actually White's King at
least can run White's King can run
towards the center if it gets checked
but uh I think black's King is worse
out of the two he's going for checkmate
Shack but is he gonna get mated himself
yeah the white Pawn is simply going to
step forward attack The Rook yeah
and there Comes The Rook will move and
now make big trouble for Shaq but
candida finish him off yeah that's the
big question for example candida slide
his Rook across maybe that's one idea to
try and go for the black king in the
corner
um you have to calculate this well it's
a scramble 20 seconds left each each
player maybe that's not the best move
even maybe there's others so he does
need to to protect this Pawn
he is actually giving it away so if that
poem was captured there would have been
a really nice check mating idea on the
eighth rank which would have gone up to
the top of the board and trapped the
black king in the corner so Black's King
has to come out first
temporarily Duda is two pawns up
I really like what he did actually
keeping things simple on his last move
getting rid of one of Black's pawns and
two Pawn Advantage like you said if he
can keep that white Pawn on the E7
Square which he's just done protecting
it
he should win the game
aha that white Pawn on E7 is too strong
it paralyzes a whole Nook on its own and
White's got a threat White's Bishop is
going to slide one square across on the
diagonal to go into tackle Black's Rook
at the top of the board if you can kick
away the blockader it's game over it is
game over and I feel the only chance
that Shaq has is basically to give a
rook a check and we see him capture a
pawn and the King swiftly steps up
your threat is going to happen David the
bishop is going to go and attack the
rook and Duda will be winning
yeah and while the evaluation bars shop
right up completely winning now for
white wow white king is out of danger
Kings in end games if they're in the
corner they can get trapped if they're
in the center nearly never because they
can run anywhere and look at this the
king active Shack shaking his head
Black's rook and Bishop they're tied up
in knots the black Rook has to move he
has to keep defending its Bishop but uh
yeah the other Rook is gonna drop and
Shaq looks away he knows his position is
lost and it's over he lets his clock run
out Shaq and he loses the game two wow
Duda takes the lead 40 moves with the
white pieces winning game two to take
the lead uh he will now have to make a
comeback